there's so many better show concepts I
mean I think I'll sit down with you in a
writers room okay
I was will brainstorm because this isn't
it hey what's going on everybody four
first we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by david dobrik
he's the king of the internet with more
than 23 million subscribers between his
channels david dobrik and david dobrik
two massive collabs vlog squad hijinks
and every once in a while we'll give
away a very expensive car david dobrik
welcome to the show thank you for having
me on the show I'm so nervous
you're nervous yeah are you a spicy food
guy no not at all and like I want to
like I want to say this before we begin
if like I look like I'm overreacting
towards the end I'm not like I'm not
playing it up for your camera I'm
genuinely so bad with spicy food like
the worst
[Music]
this may be too much for me
good I can do that
[Music]
since we touched down up top you're one
of YouTube's most successful stars with
nearly two and a half billion views and
2019 alone of all the science
experiments that have gone awry in your
living room which one is the biggest
pain in the ass to clean up we did we
did one where we had like a dry film
experiment basically and there was foam
it was a foam explosion that was in my
backyard and it blew up everywhere and
it died a half of the house green and it
died like my outdoor furniture green and
you can't get it out because it's like a
weird chemical and then my neighbors
below me they this is I haven't told
this anybody but the neighbor below me
complained and he said a piece of the
foam hit his wife while she was in the
hot tub and burned her which is
impossible because the second the foam
comes out it's like you can touch you
could play with it you could rub it all
over your skin but um he was trying to
get me in trouble and he was like yeah
burned my wife in the hot tub he saw a
bag I think you know yeah he saw his
opportunity but um but not today
his his vlog II never led you to any
bizarre run-ins with law enforcement oh
my god all the time it's like one time I
got in trouble we were doing donuts in a
parking lot I was celebrating because I
just bought my dad a new car so it was
him doing the doughnuts in the parking
lot so I explained to the cop what we
were doing a music okay that's fine just
go do this somewhere else please do you
have a most memorable trip to the
emergency room most memorable trip oh
yeah for sure I am we're we were this is
juggling the wine bottles yes it sounds
too rude juggling wine bottles one of
the wine bottles hit the floor and I was
reaching down as it hit the floor and I
got it just when it broke and it went
right into my hand and which hand yeah
maybe this car's gone oh my god and yet
I could cut my hand what I liked about
that is you really leaned into it cuz
you're like this is the thumbnail get
the shot don't stop running the cameras
yeah that was such a cool moment cuz all
my friends were there so we were all
there to like go through this experience
and me going in the emergency room
what's your philosophy on titling
YouTube videos because you seem to kind
of bury the lead from time to time right
okay yeah that's interesting that you
notice that yeah I don't sometimes I
don't like giving away like the surprise
so undersell over-deliver right yeah so
like I find it like
a chance like film with a cool celeb
sometimes I like titling it something
about like my friends something to throw
people off so it's a surprise in the
video what would you want to title this
video do me out of here okay
delicious whoa this is number two it's
sort of a steep ramp up here at - ah
okay at this point if we were like at a
wings place I'd be I'd tell my friends
not to get that cuz it's too spicy
it's not even enjoyable at this point in
the two spot I love this show it's a
Chicago guy do you have a deep-dish spot
of choice yeah DUS pizzeria have you
ever been no or Illuminati's are you
definitely no natis that's my spot yeah
people don't like deep-dish yeah how do
you defend it against people that say
it's like someone's casserole or
whatever it's the worst it's so bad
everyone goes this is soup this isn't
even Pizza it's the worst thing like
especially people from New York or from
living anywhere in the world they're
like that's not even pizza oh my god the
father is there a Slovakian dish or
snack that you think could catch on as
like a mainstream menu item in the
United States the first hot dog I ever
had was actually in Slovakia but it
wasn't like there wasn't like an opening
at the top it just sat like this is a
weird mushroom it's set inside like the
bun oops right I'm fine
uh I could get oh this one I'm stuck
here but it's sat inside the bun and it
was like really cool cuz it was like the
hot dog wasn't nice and tight and
[ __ ] but yeah maybe that would catch
on
so besides being from the Northwest
Chicago suburbs making our livings on
YouTube and having amazing hair another
thing that you and I have in common is
this shared goal of one day hosting a
late-night show yes these days hosts
like Jimmy Fallon and James Corden they
compete as much for the morning after
YouTube views as they are you for the
ratings in their timeslot is there a
late-night host or segment that you
think fits especially well into the
YouTube ecosystem I think you spill your
guts or fill your guts with James Corden
it's like perfect because it's like
really intimate just like this show is
and people are eating disgusting foods
and it's like super youtuber you write
to like put weird stuff in your mouth
right here but the idea I want in
carpool karaoke those two James Corden
bits are really good I like seeing
celebrities in like a more normal
setting something that you would just
like see your friends in and I like
late-night because it like gives you the
credibility like I'm being on the
network and then you can also put your
clips on YouTube where you have like the
actual viewership for the like most
people watch and then you did a great
job on The Tonight Show sending it to
commercial oh no I did it right just
thank you though so in that honor can
you hid your camera and send us to the
next wing okay and here it's the next
wing
yeah yeah this is it it's a
rollercoaster ride here it seems yeah
we're going up again we just came down
we're definitely on happened
so between hosting last year's Teen
Choice Awards and in my humble opinion
being the standout judge on the
Nickelodeon series America's most
musical family or why're you joined a
small number of internet stars who've
broken through into a mainstream
television what's the appeal to you of
something like Netflix or a TV network
when the pipes that you've built
yourself and that you own yourself are
already going to millions of people yeah
I think it's just um I think it's just
the credibility behind it like I think
it's like people still don't have the
same respect for digital influencers
like they do for a traditional talent
and I totally get that because the
internet like you can upload one hour
you can upload whenever and whatever you
want so there's no like regulation so
people upload some really stupid [ __ ] on
there so it's kind of hard to filter out
like who the good eggs and the bad eggs
are on internet and that's why I like
youtubers in like a general sense get
all the ones they get like a bad rap but
being on a network what gives you gives
you pretty solid credibility this is a
[ __ ] show when you think about facepalm
moments that you've maybe had with
brands or executives over the years no
reason to name names but I'm not gonna
stop you from naming names is there a
story that stands out yeah actually
there is I had um I had a moment with a
company at a music festival and I I
don't want to say the company cuz I know
they're gonna come after me
but um I filmed like I felt like a snake
on the ground like I filmed a bunch of
random stuff around the festival and
they made me cut out like 70% of my
video cuz they were like we don't want
the festival look like they have snakes
and like the whole thing he was like
completely botched and they made me cut
everything on my video and I hate that I
hate when like brands don't give you
creative control
okay let's do it hmm
this one's delicious it seems like we're
almost sort of going run off with you
right now
[Music]
all right David we every current segment
on our show called explain that Graham
where do a deep dive on I guess
Instagram poll interesting pictures that
need more context so we'll show you the
picture you just tell us the bigger
story and then oh here you are you
brought a 300-pound alligator to one of
your friends houses Jane Rizzoli yeah so
big
is there a prank that you're most proud
of over the years there's one my friend
told me he's his really scare my friend
I got into an argument about who would
be more scared during an earthquake so
we had on to the next day we had a fake
police officers come to the door and
tell him that the San Andreas Fault was
about to rupture and we have to evacuate
California she's gonna fall into the
pistol right and he started freaking out
and as he exited we hired like 3040
extras to be outside of the house like
all packing their cars like they're the
neighbors and we had like a woman with
like a baby running down the street and
it like [ __ ] him up so bad that I had
to apologize to each member of his
family the next day he gave him PTSD
yeah it was like it was I felt really
bad but he's like had to be bad um but
it was great but yeah I had to calls mom
I just sorry to cause dad had to say
sorry much like you're gonna have to
apologize to me after the show when I'm
on the toilet and it's gonna be the
whole works pay them I'll hit me on
FaceTime David I know you got the number
up next I know that you represented
Vernon Hills High School at the 2014 IHS
a state tournament Wow
yeah do you have any tennis tips for
beginners I hate when people tell me
they play tennis when they don't
actually play tennis I faked Isis a
sport where you can't like go out and
just play with anybody like you have to
find a lifestyle to be about it about it
you have to find someone else like on
the same level as you for you to enjoy
it
I'm gonna throw up right on you all
right limbani
is my my favorite Instagram follow for
the last couple of years what was it
like to spend an afternoon with the
legend he's so kind
he's so humble - he's missing a poly is
huge but he's just so generous it's
insane
being around a chimp there are literally
humans yeah well sometimes I'll see him
and he'll unscrew his Gatorade and then
drink it and then screw the top back
anyway yeah he helped it on my friends
tie his shoe because my friend is a
little bit slower no they're like
they're honestly slower humans like
that's what they are like when like when
you look at a chimp you're not even
impressed you're kind of just like oh I
wish he was smarter because he remind
you so much of a human that you're just
like he's he's almost there he's at the
cusp of being a real person all right
and last why was this the greatest
moment of your life I've had to host the
Teen Choice Awards and um Robert Downey
jr. trailer will has right across from
mine and I love Iron Man like I'm
obsessed with him so I told like my team
to tell me when he was coming up and and
like three hours later be like he's
coming he's getting her his car so I was
like studying my lines in my trailer and
I opened the door and I come out and I
go hi and my voice cracked it is the
most embarrassing thing and he looks at
me he goes who are you tell me
everything and I'm shaking his hand
that's like a long heater chick and I'm
like I'm David and your biggest fan I
don't know what to say and I just
[ __ ] panicked and I went right back
into my dressing room and I just like I
slumped into my room into my into the
chair and I remember Natalie my sister
coming in and she was just like you
[ __ ] loser
I [ __ ] panicked and the best part
about it is an hour later I opened up
the Teen Choice Awards cuz I was a host
and there he is
like sitting on the side of me like
wondering like who the [ __ ] is this guy
he just had a panic attack and try to me
and now he's host in this [ __ ] show
that was one of the that was one of my
favorite moments for sure all right
David baby already I could tell you more
about me yeah I think I get think I get
the gist
[Music]
and then I should say in the six spot a
big part we usually we have this a Thai
green chili sauce this season but fiyah
fiyah making a return because David you
have a coconut allergy and so now we've
brought this one back honestly I make of
my allergies let's just say I'm allergic
to certain things that I don't like you
know I'm actually allergic to the last
app so I've heard you say that in your
years of vlogging and podcasts you
shared almost everything about your life
does providing that kind of access to
people ever backfire on you I know that
you've had this problem with people
showing up to your house yeah people
will come to my house and they'll think
oh I think they're my friend because
you're losing ream out here cause I
still see it I still see the life in
your eyes David eat like though people
will show up at my house at like 11:00
oh my [ __ ] oh my god people will show up
in my house like 11 and they'll be like
in the back let's go get beers and I'll
be like this is so weird
have you uh have you ramped up security
or done anything like that yes we have
we have ramped up security but it really
doesn't stop people and my neighbors are
getting really mad this is brutal this
is bad I'm embarrassed don't be
embarrassed you're doing great David
a fan is somebody who respects your
boundaries and somebody takes two pars
like
shows up at your house right let me ask
the questions
problem is shit's crazy this shit's
crazy well if you think that's great
strong yes have tissues too cuz I'm
about to be blowing snot everywhere oh
[Music]
so you've done some monster collabs on
your channel everyone from Paris Hilton
to Justin Bieber do you remember the
first celebrity that you ever lured onto
the vlog we basically had to trick Tony
Yayo into shooting the hot ones pile oh
yeah yeah it was steve-o I got him like
my second video I just ran right into
meta movie premiere and I said can you
please be in this teaser sure but like
my first like genuine person that like I
was filming like a lot was Josh Peck
this course in waves it's going what do
you think you're fine you got it like a
adopted Josh yeah now josh is like my
tryout is crazy
your format is so free-flowing thank you
I'm curious on the mechanics on how you
get some of these huge cloud monsters
like when you're on a Tesla with Justin
Bieber are you guys secretly on like a
movie set with 10 bodyguards there or no
not at all it's always like it's always
just me in the camera well with Justin
yeah like I when I pulled up to his
house to pick him up he had literally
like the militia right outside of his
house like it is a full-on army and then
they follow you around I'm gonna make
sure you're okay but we just went to
UCLA and we pulled up in front of a
sorority and we had people come in and
we surprised them
what's the next week we're not better
yet would you like to be sprint to the
finish line this is when I imagine this
show I thought it's gonna be like like
my eyes gonna be watering like I thought
it would be like funny but it's painful
it's pain its pain I'm experiencing it's
not like joy joyous like discomfort you
know I think but it's cuz it's it's you
in the chair
you know the person is always
experiencing that but that is what's
funny like right now you're being very
funny
okay here we go
[Music]
Oh oh yeah immediate right there so I
saw a video that you'd ever Vanity Fair
where you mentioned in passing that you
get nightmares in fact you said I have
nightmares more than I dream I feel like
I'm in one right now is there a
particular nightmare
that comes to mind now that we're on to
bomb I'll be honest with you nothing
comes to mind when I walked in here it's
a big crew a lot of cameras right now
it's just me and your mother there's
nothing else I see I'm like [ __ ]
blacked out do you have like recurring
nightmares ever they're only like themes
are there anything is there anything
that recurs I used to have one when I
was in the backseat of my car and I
would take my eyeball out you know put
it in the cup holder I know you said
haven't went a lot I don't have it
do you believe in ghosts partially but
here's my explanation to that if I was
to actually see a ghost in real life
like many people have claimed they have
seen they would spend the rest of my
life dedicated to finding this [ __ ]
ghost look I don't understand how people
just bring it up casually in
conversation go oh yeah I saw it ghost
like [ __ ] that if I saw a ghost that's
all I would talk about right I see why
people would like they devote their
lives to Bigfoot like if they think they
saw Bigfoot
I understand devoting your life to it
you know this next one is the Widowmaker
from Australia okay let's do it let's go
what did it mean to you to win a
reader's choice for sexiest heartthrob
from People magazine edging out the
likes of Harry Styles and Shawn Mendes I
meant nothing why do you ride so hard
for saddle ranch I love that went I did
actually didn't mean something to me
that I won that oh my god
careful around your face you know the
cross-pollination I love salads my third
bar and I was so surprised that I want I
couldn't believe that a bit hairstyles
and shot of mine that's incredible [ __ ]
this man
have you ever ridden that bull at saddle
ranch there's so many better show
concepts I mean I think I'll sit down
with the you know writers room okay
I was well brainstorm cuz this isn't it
have you ever ridden that bull at saddle
ranch yeah no yeah I have once like a
really long time that's where I met you
I met you at saddle ranch is that crazy
and then that's when I met a Jeff so I'm
fascinated by it by the way yeah I'm
hoping good like you could still hear
yourself in the interview because all I
hear is this
if the vlog squad
faze clan it looks like you're getting
ready you like - like inject me with a
syringe I literally feel like I'm at the
doctor's office and you're like trying
to make conversation with me while
you're like putting the alcohol swab on
and team ten we're all given a million
dollars to make a youtube video who do
you think would get the most views oh
[ __ ]
poly team ten big paw we'll figure out
something
I'm gonna get that tissue box ago I was
confident when I threw it but
all [ __ ] man this is bad
alright David this is the last dab we
call it the last a because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing okay you don't
have to if you don't want to know I
definitely will
I would not want to piss you off I see
what you're capable of
don't want to be on your bad side did I
do it yeah that's enough that's that's
good that's plain that's plenty
I'm scary the showman okay you want to
ask me a question right now while I'm
calm but you have one right in the
Avenue area well you know what okay cuz
when I eat that wine I'm [ __ ]
I actually don't have a question for you
David but I would like to close out the
show right in david dobrik style Eric do
you have the the camera because it look
like it looks like I'm in a movie
pretending to be a youtuber before we
take the bite I would just like to hand
it over to you David to vlog this final
wing and the end of the show here's the
final wing at the end of the show it's
the last AB
okay here we go
cheers Cheers
[Music]
is that the Carolina Reaper pepper no
but the guy who grew the Carolina Reaper
pepper
he made this sauce this is with pepper X
have you ever had a Carolina Reaper yeah
I have a pepper guy and he grows you
like he'll like meat mean like those
sketchiest places I don't think I make a
deal
ya know it wasn't that bad or it hasn't
kicked in yet it hasn't kicked in yet it
is bad someone take this throw it at
handy and over the reigns almost lost
the camera shaky hands david dobrik all
the way to the end of hot ones and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my friend this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life honestly I'm gonna be
puking for the next couple hours but if
you want to see me on my special yes
it's that david dobrik and i know I was
like [ __ ] on this concept because
I'm like so stressed out but I genuinely
love the show and I'm so happy for you
and congrats on our success but I'm
never ever coming funky even in a 30
foot radius of you ever
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's also a stop the tastebuds way to
go
sauce 1/3 peg Anita's calm Ketchum on
hot ones the game show